على كل حال سالنا الناس مشاهدينا في
السعوديه عن رايهم في احتماليه انتقال
ميسي الى نادي الهلال السعودي خلونا نشوف
شو قالوا
كيف هذا شيء طيب يعني بالنسبه للانديه
السعوديه واحنا نرى ان شاء الله انه في
تقدم افضل والله هذا خبر بيكون مفرح جدا
وخاصه اذا كان في نادي الهلال
بيكون بالعكس بيكون شيء طيب للهلال وطيب
لمسي في نفس الوقت انه يكون يشارك في احد
او انجح الانديه السعوديه اللي هو نادي
الهلال يضيفون نقله نوعيه لان تشوف مثلا
الحين مثلا المباريات من قبل يتابعونك
مليون الان مثلا دخل رونالدو اللي يتابعون
سبعه مليون مو فقط على المستوى العربي
وميسي كذلك نفس الشيء مره كويسه ما شاء
الله له اسمه يعني سمعته حلوه اوف عاد هذه
ما شاء الله تبارك الله عندنا كريستيانو
ويجينا ميسي من قدنا قول لي بالله مين
قدنا هذا شيء جميل جدا بالعكس هذه الاضافه
للكره السعوديه والدوري تبعنا يكون من
اكبر
الدوريات اللي موجوده على مستوى العالم
حيصبح هاي صلت الاضواء اكثر على المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وهيكون في تنافس ما بين
الهلال وما بين النصر كريستيانو وميسي
الاثنين من القطبين من اقطاب كره القدم
على مستوى العالم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات